the ongoing wave of sexual harassment
scandals claimed another high-profile
target this week Minnesota senator Al
Franken announced his resignation after
several women accused him of
inappropriate conduct but as Franken
himself noted in a Senate floor speech
other accused men including Alabama
Senate candidate
Rory Moore and President Trump himself
have yet to face consequences from the
accusations against them to talk about
this we're joined by New York Times
op-ed columnist Michelle Goldberg whose
most recent column covered the topic
Michelle welcome hey thank you for
having me so one of the things you
raised in your columns is this idea that
principle may be becoming partisan what
does that mean well I think that there
are vastly different incentives in the
two parties I mean the Democratic Party
although they're certainly driven by
cynical partisan motives like anybody
else they also have a base that is
largely female that largely aspires to a
world without pervasive sexual
harassment and you know they promote
ideas of gender equality which made
having even someone accused of the sort
of transgressions that Al Franken is
accused of which pale beside what Roy
Moore or Donald Trump has been accused
of it made his future in the party
untenable
whereas Republicans largely not
exclusively but largely don't care and
so there is really no pressure to have
consequences for some of the kind of
rapid abuse the the rampant abuse in
there well you think you did have trent
franks right well ted freeze a little
bit different right because trent banks
is actually doesn't quite fall under the
rubric of me too i actually don't think
that there are a lot of women out there
who can say that their bosses press them
to carry their children in surrogates
right I mean this is this sort of like
monstrous freakish aberration that if
anything just reifies the idea that the
Republican Party is the party of The
Handmaid's Tale if you you say in your
column that if this is a cultural
revolution revolución is smaller than it
appears yes because it only because it's
a revolution that really depends on
people's susceptibility to shame so it's
only really taking place in realms like
the Democratic Party the media Hollywood
the arts
we're we're publicity and public censure
can have an impact right so it's why
Donald Trump has been so far completely
immune to its effect right as you
pointed out it hasn't yet rocked
corporate America Wall Street right I
don't think anybody out there believes
that Wall Street is less rife with
harassment than you know the news media
or public radio it's simply the
incentive structure for people coming
forward is a lot different but let's
also be clear that while the Democrats
are sort of positioning this as the sort
of right moral choice for Franken to
resign it is also the politically the
most expeditious path to choose right
this Democrats will use Roy Moore and Al
Franken as comparison tests in 2018 will
they not right but I think that that's
the point I mean for the so the point is
not that the Democratic Party is you
know operate operating out of pure
unblemished principle it's that the
incentives for the Democratic Party push
for decency on this issue and I think
the incentives in the Republican Party
push for apologizing for the most
grotesque kinds of sexual or at least
apologizing or at least in the or
denying is is there a point Michele that
that you know as more and more of these
figures fall from grace is there a point
that we get desensitized to this my fear
is yes and more than desensitized that
the backlash comes where people decide
that this is just how men in the
workplace are yeah and so I think that
we have to be really careful and
vigilant and most women I know don't
feel triumphant at this moment most a
lot of women I know are extremely
apprehensive and you know ya think that
the backlash is gonna gather force well
to that end you talk and one where your
column is about something called a sex
panic mm-hmm what does that mean for
people unfamiliar with the term well
it's basically when you have these sorts
of moral outrages and you know lack of
due process I mean maybe the most
salient example would be the daycare
satanic sexual abuse panic of I believe
the 80s maybe the 90s when you had all
these wild accusations but people
actually going to jail for ideas about
you know children in daycare being
abused by these satanic cults and it was
really a think something that was
a lot of anxiety about daycare as an
institution and working women I don't
think that's where we are but I do think
that America is vulnerable to sex panics
and is sort of vulnerable to these moral
Crusades and where people end up getting
steamrolled it's an ongoing development
Michelle Goldberg thank you very time